a second attempt to evacuate civilians
from ukraine's southeastern city of
mariopol has failed residents were
expected to leave the city today during
a 10 am to 9 pm local ceasefire
ukrainian officials say evacuations were
stopped due to continued russian
shelling another attempt to evacuate
mario poll and another city besieged by
moscow's troops in southeastern ukraine
was also called off on saturday both
sides accused the other violating a
temporary truce some two hundred
thousand civilians are trapped in
mariupol which continues to be without
water and electricity and is fast
running out of food
let's cross to our correspondent nick
connolly who's in kiev nick let's start
with that situation in mario poll where
the cease-fire has been broken yet again
well it's an extraordinary drama going
on there in south country it's city
we've visited often big big city on the
sea of azov that is now surrounded on
three sides with only the sea open and
even there there are russian forces and
it is as you mentioned increasingly
humanitarian drama there no power
food stocks running down
no connection people not even able to
make sure their friends and family in
other parts of the country are safe or
get messages out
the
interpretation here in kiev the
ukrainian line would be that the
russians are just not interested in
letting the civilians out that this kind
of humanitarian disaster
puts more pressure on ukraine's
leadership to make compromise with
russia that russia has already basically
priced in the reputational damage that
this invasion of ukraine has done and is
basically going to play hardball i think
it's also important to remember that
it's extraordinarily difficult for these
two sides to reach agreements even on
more technical stuff like this at a time
where hundreds if not thousands of
soldiers on both sides are dying and you
know there is just extraordinary bad
blood i think without outside
intervention some kind of intermediary
from the red cross whatever i think it's
been very difficult for them to get any
kind of manageable deal on the on the
ground
a truly shocking situation now nick
you're in kiev what's the situation it
there in the capital and the surrounds
well as you might be able to see behind
me kiev is deserted we still a couple of
hours to go till the curfew but this is
a city that basically seems to be
abandoned it's not quite true there are
lots of people hiding behind the
curtains when you see them at the
supermarket you see them kind of peering
out occasionally but on the streets for
the most part it's journalists and
soldiers checkpoints everywhere sandbags
anti-tank uh kind of devices most of
them seemingly improvised everywhere
it's pretty shocking someone like me
who's lived here for four years to see
the city basically
expecting war this is a city that
obviously a country that has lived with
war in the east since 2014 when russia
annexed crimea and stoked those
separatist conflicts in the east but
that was always a long way away there
was always a night train ride away here
in kiev you could always be forgiven for
kind of thinking that this was just a
peaceful european capital and now russia
has brought that war to the streets of
kiev and everyone here very anxious
about you know the reports we've heard
of attempts by russia to try and kill
ukraine's democratically elected
president zielenski that there could be
sleeper agents operating and now
obviously russian troops within 20-25
kilometers of the capital even though
that advance has now seemingly got
stuffed some time there are shocking
pictures coming out of the northwestern
suburbs of kiev a place called european
butcher where there's been extraordinary
fighting humanitarian problems with
people trying to get out but railways
and roads shut it is a very eerie
situation here in here
nick over recent days we've been seeing
incredible pictures of men of all ages
queuing up to volunteer for the
ukrainian army in order to slow russia's
advance we're going to take a look now
at a report about what drives some of
those volunteers nick and we'll come
back to you after
these men are determined to fight for
their country
even in the face of russian firepower
and without support from nato
here in kiev they're waiting to sign up
for the ukrainian armed forces
resolved to do their part for the war
effort
it's my duty i want to be useful i want
to help i want to protect i want to
fight back i want my family to return to
ukraine as soon as possible and i will
do my best
other volunteers are stocking up for the
battle ahead and optimistic about
victory
we know why we defend our country and
our guys that are actually standing
there and fighting
our russian military forces they know
what they are doing those guys they
don't
we know what we are doing and that's why
we will win
it's that determination that's helped
inspire volunteers from much further
afield to join the fight ukraine
military
zalenski everything it's just
everything's been inspiring even like
the country's surrounding everybody's
just like it's like galvanized everybody
i've got no illusions i've got no
romantic ideas of war or i'm going to be
some hero or make a difference or any of
this but it's
it's what i do
i mean you could die here yes possibly
get willing to do it re-work
with heavy fighting already reaching the
city of european just outside kiev it
looks likely the volunteers bravery will
soon be put to the test
it's truly hard to imagine nick how
important are these volunteers for the
war effort and the ukrainian army
well it is obviously i think
first and foremost it's about morale
it's about showing these people are
staying and that they're not running
their way not trying to get abroad get
to safety and obviously for now i think
it's not so important in terms of the
manpower the ukrainian side if we
believe they're figures and obviously
there's always an element of uh pr in
terms of revealing your own losses as
opposed to the enemies but the ukrainian
side it seems seemingly hasn't lost as
many
men yet as the russian side but it's
about showing that there is that
willingness to sacrifice
even potentially their lives for the
country and a knowledge that if this
were to drag on which it looks set to
for now that there is the willingness
there to go out and fight ukraine for
now is more dependent on uh weapons
coming in from the west ammunition more
supplies they've also been asking for
air power for planes and also for
anti-aircraft systems because right now
russia is doing very badly in the land
war there are lots endless pictures on
social media have destroyed russian uh
tanks but also of fuel uh vehicles and
other bits of infrastructure and they're
seemingly not able to keep up with the
logistics and getting stuck often having
to abandon tanks for lack of fuel um so
that's what ukraine now is really asking
for air power anti-aircraft guns to
prevent russia
driving back it's down its advantage
from the air bombing cities bombing
military installations and that is the
big request now from the ukrainian
government to its western neighbors who
for now are you know keeping back from
that and not willing quite to go that
next step and potentially uh draw aya
from vladimir putin and the russian
leadership
dw's nick connolly reporting there from
kiev nick thanks very much
you